well tis the season for car break-ins
that's what one Southern Highlands
Community is thinking after being just
bombarded by a group of people rummaging
through their cars It All Happened near
Jones and Cactus in the far South Valley
Madison Kimbrough there in that
neighborhood tonight with the story
you'll only see here on eight
this area of Glen Haven
Haven Highlands was hit
their way car to Carr trying to break in
when I woke up Monday morning to get
ready for work I saw an alert on my
phone and I looked at it and it was six
kids three on this side three on this
side going through my daughter-in-law's
car and then going through my neighbor's
car and then making their way East on
down the street Omar Richardson
recording this video on his ring camera
after receiving that alert he quickly
notified his neighbors several of them
waking up to find their cars broken into
with door handles ripped off amongst
other things there was money taken out
clothes taken out I know that they'd had
their truck rifle through but one of our
other neighbors had actually a bank car
taken and they charged a ton of things
within two hours neighbors say break-ins
have happened before in their area but
they feel it's beyond unsettling to see
a group of people go card a car it's
it's uh more scary for you know people
that have to go to work in the morning
you know what if these guys got startled
by somebody what are they willing to go
through to get away as for ways to
prevent this from happening to you
Jonathan Alvarez with Crime Stoppers of
Southern Nevada says that you should
never leave your valuables in the car
especially during the holiday season and
as for some other tips if you have a
like a car alarm making sure that you
activate that so when you lock it making
sure that like the little beep goes off
um acknowledging that that you know that
alarm actually works consider window
tint as well is a is a great option most
of our vehicle burglaries that we
respond to and that you know we see
throughout the Valley are usually crimes
of opportunity and while this
neighborhood has on-site security that
drives by on a regular basis those that
were hit yesterday morning have now
filed a police report with Metro in
Southern Highlands Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now